[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] it's five kilometers away this way
[Music]
we gotta go there
[Music]
how insane is this it feels like we're
walking up to a beach but we're on top
of a mountain oh my word this is an
actual beach i told you
[Music]
we got to swim in the mountain ocean
oh
my god it's [ __ ] freezing i'm in a
skinny dip hurry
i'm going to the knees
[Applause]
oh my word
[Applause]
you think of cape town you probably
think robin island pristine beaches
table mountain colorful houses and wine
farms along with whatever else you've
been shown through the media including
all the bad stuff but what is it
actually like through a local space is
it dangerous is it super affordable is
it as beautiful as everyone says it is
so so yes and yes my wife gabs and i are
going to take you on a journey through
cape town that you won't be able to find
on google or any news update the inner
scoop the
the gems and what you need to do to get
the most out of this strange and
wonderful city another thing before i
get stuck in this video is brought to
you by my good friends at storyblocks
which is the complete stock solution for
creators and businesses alike but more
on that later
down and gabby's not so tourism how to
get the most out of cape town guide
okay so cape town is home to two million
and something year old sandstone that
stretches hundreds of miles north and
there's this place called kahakama i'll
link it below that we're on our way to
now where you can actually see rock
paintings from ancient sand people
tribes
[Music]
these are rock painting stories
illustrated by the sand people between
2000 to 6000 years ago underneath these
two plus million year old sandstone
caves and you can actually spend a night
in one of these caves
[Music]
this is one of my most relaxing getaways
in cape town our own warm little cave
disguised in the rock base it's super
romantic i mean where else can you stay
in an actual two and something million
year old sandstone cave
[Music]
grab it
[Music]
next is the incredible star trails if
you head just outside of the city center
the stars will blow your mind
check this [ __ ]
[Music]
sunrise takes you to the ocean in cape
town you have access to the indian and
the atlantic ocean giving you the best
of both worlds the two oceans are split
just beyond k point where the indian
ocean meets the atlantic so the wind is
always offshore somewhere meaning the
waves are really good throughout cape
town from small waves that any beginner
could ride to some of the biggest waves
in the world or what i like medium-sized
[Music]
so
[Music]
how sharky are the waters well there
have been 28 attacks in the last 60
years where seven of them have been
fatal those stats are less than the 76
attacks in california sharks are
everywhere i wouldn't worry about it too
much the beaches in cape town are
beautiful and safe during the day
however there may be a random
pickpocketer that may pinch your back so
always leave it with someone if you're
going swimming or have it right next to
you at all times then the diving is
incredible where you can dive with seals
you can dive through caves
and in the picturesque forests
look i don't want to dive into crime and
whatnot but it's a reality that should
be mentioned looking at a map from above
of the statistics gathered from an
article written by lorato bombo on the
26th of may 2021 for the growth
backpacker that states the areas to
avoid are the cape flats which is known
for high crime rates and situated in the
southeast of the cbd area and it's ruled
by gangs
then langa and nyanga these two areas
are the oldest and the poorest townships
in cape town therefore crime rates are
relatively high and it's just not safe
for tourists however i wouldn't say to
avoid these areas but definitely be
street wise as there are many great
people and good friends of mine that
live in these communities these
townships are home to many unsung heroes
and incredible initiatives like my good
friend luffy who infuses tasty bread
with spinach to spread much needed
nutrients through the community
we are currently in flower heaven just
15 minutes drive outside of the city
center and you get to this beautiful
flowers of all different colors gabs and
i love coming here
[Music]
then the mountains stretch so much
further than just table mountain there
are 87 different mountain trails in cape
town through waterfalls scenic fauna and
flora and even sandy beaches on top of
the mountains
cape town is home to some of the
greatest music festivals in the southern
hemisphere with different cultures and
genres coming together from psychedelic
trance music to township funk whatever
you're into cape town has you covered
before signing this video out i just
want to tell you a little bit more about
the sponsor of this video storyblocks
which is the complete stock solution for
creators and businesses alike providing
an unlimited library of high quality
royalty-free video audio and images
through flexible subscription plans
storyblocks is just such a great way to
speed up your creative process their
site really does have the highest
quality stocks footage textures
illustrations everything you need to do
what you do best or essentially tell a
story in the most visual way for my
motion scrapbooking segments i use
storyblock stocks like what you just saw
with a demand driven library of over 1
million assets strong all yours to
download and use anywhere you're bound
to find what you need with an unlimited
all-access subscription plan storyblocks
is also committed to building a diverse
and inclusive library and is actively
working with directors creators and
filmmakers from underrepresented
communities to build new footage
collections so that these communities
can be authentically represented in
stock a place where these groups
traditionally have not been represented
you can learn more about this initiative
called restock as well as subscribe to
storyblocks and get in on unlimited high
quality footage if you click on the link
in my description clicking on that link
helps support my channel as well as
helps you become a better filmmaker so
yeah thank you storyblocks other than
that don't forget you're awesome bruh
and i'll see you next week
[Music]
you